everyone talks about passion legacy
purpose yeah the one word to pay
attention to his energy I think the
biggest shift in our lives the things
that makes us the happiest is that when
somebody helps us identify our natural
giftedness when you figure out who you
are and do all that you win wanna be
happy will the life's not just a
business what's that belief nation it's
Evan I believe in you and this channel
is designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's live your
best believed life and learn five ways
to find your purpose also if you want to
know what Mel Robbins Tom Bilyeu Robin
Sharma and others have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days and I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
if you didn't give a [ __ ] what anybody
else thought what's the thing you would
love to be doing with your life there's
a gap between who people are and what
they tell you they want to accomplish
and so stop resisting I encourage you
stop resisting the natural flow of epic
performance stop resisting the natural
seasons of life
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one
chase energy with Mel Robbins I think
you should chase what energizes you
everyone talks about passion legacy
purpose yeah the one word to pay
attention to his energy I love that
that's it let's simplify this okay so
whatever energizes you naturally expands
you feels like possibility is exciting
to do and maybe scary that doesn't
matter it has to do with how it makes
you feel right when you were in your 20s
money made you feel good it expanded you
it energized you chasing the money that
was the game that was your passion that
was your per there's nothing wrong with
that
nothing wrong with that and I
particularly want to say that to the
women that are well yeah because it is
socialized into women not to chase
success like that not to go after the
money and so if what energizes you is
amassing wealth go for it but what
happened and and the reason why I say
that is because people talk about the
word passion yeah or purpose right and
the truth is it's not a person place or
a thing it's not it is the feeling of
being expanded and energized right if
you're pursuing your passion it means
that you wake up every day and our
energized so instead of trying to think
what's my purpose
fashion was my purpose watch my fashion
Kurt oh god yeah instead of thinking
like that I want you instead to ask
yourself what's what could I do today
that would energize me what energizes me
if it's making money
figure out how to make money if it is
making a difference figure out how to
make a difference it could be in any
single shape or form but if it energizes
you that's what you need to follow and
what happens is that passion also
because it's energy it dissipates over
time because when you first start making
money it's thrilling yeah
thrilling there is nothing more
exhilarating than making your first
million yeah nothing more exhilarating
but what happens is once you learn how
to do something once you can do it over
and over again and so it starts to
become routine yeah which means it's no
longer energizing right which is why
every entrepreneur out there goes
through the mode of chasing the money
and then you hit the money that you need
to make then you're like I'm not
fulfilled yeah do that finally you know
I do think yes yeah and it's because you
were energized by the money and now
you're not yeah now you got to be
energized by the next thing rule number
two get in touch with your gifts with an
ED mind light when I was small mom
I was also really under sized so it's
probably the reason I lift weights I was
always there every baseball picture on
the kid holding the sign in the front
right so I was small and skinny these
two teased me Eddie spaghetti you know
and I'd get bullied at school and I
never retaliated so I had that mix with
shyness mixed with chaos in my home
which many people can relate to and I
got to tell you the the shift for me
sports was good for me because it gave
me an al that I finally found something
that I was pretty good at I think the
biggest shift in our lives the things
that makes us the happiest is that when
somebody helps us identify our natural
giftedness and when I was a little boy
when I got a little bit older they
pointed out my speed so wasn't my lack
of size I was fast
I was the fast kid right I always wanted
to be fast kid and I got confidence in
baseball doing that when I got into
business I said you know you're intense
when someone points out a gift about you
that you also kind of intuitively know
to be true they're linked to them if
you're intense you're passionate
you won't get out work you're relentless
I want I am those things and when
someone linked those gifts to me winning
now I believed I could win that's the
other way to change identity is when
someone can link your giftedness to the
victory you'll believe it not like
you're great that's general that's bull
but it's something you know specific
like for you right now
you wouldn't brag them there's a few
things you know you know what I am good
at these things
right I've always been good at these
things it's natural for me and when
someone links that to you winning like
for you for example you're an
unbelievable interviewer you have this
general you you you don't need to be the
smartest person in the room because you
probably are most of the time and so
there's a confidence know there's a
confidence that allows you to be present
when you interview me and just listen
that's different than anyone who's
interviewed me before and so that's a
natural giftedness for you which is why
there's a part of you that kind of knows
I am pretty you wouldn't say if I am
pretty good at this this is a good
program and so the way we change our
identity the way I changed mine was by
getting in touch with what some of my
natural gifts were and then using them
in my career using them in my life that
shifted the weight right off of me
because the weight was I suck I'm shy
I'm small I have a screwed-up family
that's the weight right the lifting off
of the way it is these are some gifts
God gave me or the universe gave me or
that at least I know I have and I can
spend my life using these gifts now I've
got hope now my identity is changing now
my life takes a different direction rule
number three encounter different stuff
with Tom Bill you here's how you develop
a passion it starts as a minor area of
interest you gain areas of interest by
encountering a lot of stuff so if you
have encountered a lot of things in your
life go out there and encounter stuff go
sailing go take a dance class go study
neuroscience like whatever it is just
encounter a whole bunch of very broad
diverse things from that you're gonna
get sparks of interest like oh I
actually found that interesting I want
to learn more dive deep through
engagement not through pondering through
engagement you're going to realize
whether something is gonna turn into an
area of fascination so as you go deeper
into it you're gonna either become
fascinated or you're not if you're not
fascinated move on if you are fascinated
then that's an area where you're gonna
ask yourself one very simple question do
I want to become the best in the world
at that thing if you do if you want to
become truly extraordinary in that thing
then go down the path of gain
mastery now the reason I think that it's
wise to ask that question going in is
when you frame it up I'm gonna become
the best in the world at this
immediately people understand the amount
of time energy and weight that it would
take to become truly great at that thing
and I don't think that passion can
happen unless you're becoming truly
great at that thing that's part of
passion I don't think people are deeply
passionate about something that they
really suck at and I'll give you an
example I love video games I absolutely
love playing first-person shooters I
learn a lot from them I get a lot out of
them
I really just intrinsically enjoy the
time it has both that sense of eating a
cake because it's just fun in the moment
and it I pull from it life lessons
business lessons I practice getting out
of the sympathetic nervous system into
the parasympathetic nervous system it's
literally gamified so I'm getting better
I have points I can you know have my
improvement turned into metrics it's all
of it I really really enjoy but I won't
say that I'm deeply passionate about
extensions not that good at it so it's
one of those things if I really wanted
to develop a deep passion for video
video games and put it at the center of
my life that then I would set down that
path of really practicing now this is
like this is the most important thing
that passion will do for you which is
it's gonna pull you through boredom it's
gonna pull you through the hard times
and that's why it's really got to be
something that you just are prepared to
become great at because when you're
prepared to become great there's just
these insane moments of boredom
repetition and all of that and if you
have this burgeoning passion coming out
of that that's what's going to give you
the energy to get through it so it's
this symbiotic relationship between a
developing passion and how hard it is to
actually really get great at something
so the things that you get great at need
to be something that is this developing
passion so there you have it that's how
you do it and then that's why you do it
rule number four figure out who you are
with Gary Vaynerchuk I just can't
explain to everybody like clearer when
you figure out who you are and do all
that you win if you're great a painting
paint and hire a partner to be your
salesperson if somebody at 20 years old
made me their business partner as a
painter they'd be the most famous
painter in the world yet most
painters wanna be the salesman and
businessmen and women as well as the
painter and there's a problem
85% of painting 90% of people that are
great a painting are artists and don't
have the DNA to sell and vice versa all
my sales friends and business friends
that want to start all these businesses
around something creative I've got news
for you Joel you know you can be a great
salesman but your pottery suction and so
that's that so like in its that's a very
funny analogy for the following figure
out who you are don't apologize for who
you are and then become even greater
than you naturally are at what you are
well that's the whole the whole the
whole games broken because everybody's
too tied up into other people's opinions
I only care about my opinion myself and
I care what my mom and wife and kids and
the world think just not as much as I
care about the way I think about myself
and I and that's it just that slight
advantage and I think most of you care
more about what other people think than
what you think about yourself
and or you actually don't feel good
about yourself right the thing that made
me smile when you just introduced me you
said I'm one of the most motivational
people in the world , and everybody I
know that's medam said he's the nicest
guy there's no comparison to the better
feeling of people that have actually
gotten to know me say that versus
millions hundreds of thousands tens of
thousands thinking I'm the coolest and
and and that's it I mean that's it and
that's why it's and that's why it's easy
for me to feel good about myself
right and so I think a lot of people
need to start with themselves maybe the
reason they don't have more confidence
in themselves or care about their
opinion about themselves versus others
is because they know they're doing
things they don't like so they need to
work on that I get offered an emailed
5,000 different requests for podcasts
and shows and what what I think my
friend here on let's see his name Evan
bow-bow let's send it in beau I'm sorry
Evan Carmichael introduced me to vote
well Beau's figured out his time as the
asset and so if you want Kevin Hart or
the rock or or Beyonce or ja rule or
Richard Branson or Tony Shea or Sheryl
Sandberg on your podcast maybe you
should start the hundred twenty second
podcast and then you got to be creative
and try to figure out how you get maybe
you create the one question video show
that's it no shows one question promised
you a lot of people that you want as
guests if they see in the headline I
just need four minutes of your time for
the one question show a lot more gonna
say yes then can you be on my podcast
for an hour and a half and rule number
five the last twenty four very special
bonus clip is change your perspective
with Robin Sharma a brain tattoo I love
sharing with my audiences is this one a
job is only just a job if you see it as
a job and so why would you lose the
opportunity to leverage what you do
every day to grow your happiness to grow
your energy to allow you to release more
your talents into the world to allow you
to help more people why would you miss
that opportunity by falling into the
trap of thinking this isn't just my job
I'm just getting up in the morning I'm
working 9:00 to 5:00 going down to the
coal mine every day and you could say
well Robin this doesn't apply to me you
know I just have a ordinary job well
I've got to tell you I've met taxi
drivers who feel their work is
incredibly meaningful I mean I was at
LaGuardia and I remember you know being
in a taxicab and the man had this white
shirt and his tab was perfection
and I said you know your attitude is
great your passion is awesome your your
cab is perfect you've got this fresh
newspaper for me to read what is your
psychology that allows you to do this
and he said Robin this is not a dirty
job it's an important job I get to make
a difference I remember being
Johannesburg meeting the janitor in the
Joe
aniss berg men's room or WC who worked
like he was the Elon Musk of what he did
his he worked like Pavarotti saying and
so my point is simply this it's really
your choice as to how you will view the
work you do every day and even in the
most quote-unquote ordinary of work you
can find gold and if you connect with
the gold you connect with the meaning
and if you connect with the meaning you
connect with your talents then you
connect with your talents you connect
with the best within you and if you
connect with the best within you you go
to work every day and you are this
shining star of world class and you
become the Picasso of your industry and
everything else takes care of itself now
got a really special bonus tip with me
don't think you're gonna enjoy but
before that is time for the three-point
landing questions time to move from just
watching into the video to take an
action in your life for business and if
you're feeling bold leave your answers
in the comments below here we go
question number one how do you need to
change your perspective remember - what
different things will you commit to
discovery this week and number three
what energy did you need to chase if you
are not happy in life it's because
you're not serving enough I believe that
humans are good 99.999% of humans are
good there's a tiny little fraction of a
percent of people who enjoy giving harm
and hurting others because they have
some chemical imbalance but apart from
that people are good and we are
connected to each other your highest
purpose in life will come from helping
others but the next question becomes Wow
how do I do it how do I find my higher
purpose how do I know what I'm supposed
to do how do I get Direction I'm gonna
give you the 3-step process about called
the purpose planner that won't give you
the clarity that you're looking for I
break it down into your who your why and
your how let's start with the who your
who is your one word most important core
value everybody has a core value if
you're a human being you have a core
value that you believe in more than
anything else and when you understand
who you are when you understand your
single most important core value then
you're less likely to be swayed by other
people
your
likely to live somebody else's version
of your life because they have clarity
and you don't when you do not have
clarity you end up chasing everybody
else's clarity you end up doing their
version because they have certainty and
you have no idea what you're doing it's
like you're walking on quicksand and
you're constantly sinking and you know
this is something greater for you your
one word your most important core value
is the rock that you stand on when the
rest of the world is crumbling around
you so for me is belief my one word is
belief that's what I stand on if you
love believe you're gonna be a huge
friend of this channel because I talk
about it in some form in every video
every video should use believe if you
hate believe you're probably gone by now
you hate my channel and that's okay go
go do your thing somewhere else you need
to figure out your who you need to
figure out what your one word most
important core value is that becomes the
lens through which you see your entire
world and attracts the goodness into
your life step number two as your why
why do you do what you do now I'm a big
believer that your purpose comes from
your pain that whatever your most
painful moment was in life whatever you
struggled with the most growing up in
life whatever moment in life you felt
the most worthless as a human being your
highest purpose your greatest joy and
satisfaction will come from helping
people who are currently feeling the way
that you felt who are currently facing
that situation that you were in that you
hated the thing that you would never
wish upon anybody else in the world lots
of people are going through that thing
and if you can step in and help those
people that's gonna be so filling up
your soul I can't even explain it to you
for me my one word is believed that's my
who my why is I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur I hated my life I was
struggling as making three hundred
dollars a month I felt worthless as a
human I felt like I was bringing no
value to the world and that was
massively frustrating I felt alone I
didn't know what to do that's why I love
helping entrepreneurs
I love believing in entrepreneurs why
entrepreneurs could be anybody could
believe in anybody believe it's at the
core of Who I am it's my one word most
important core value but I could be
believe it in anybody and I do and I
love it but entrepreneurs hold that
special spot for me and the startup
entrepreneurs not the ones who are
already making tons of money I love them
too but I resonates so much more with
the startup entrepreneurs because I
remember what it's like eating at
McDonald's and only
afford french fries and set up an entire
meal so your why your purpose comes from
your pain figure out what that most
painful moment was for you and it's hard
cuz entrepreneurs we like looking and
being optimistic and looking forward and
being positive but it's in that pain
that your answer actually is find out
what that most painful moment was your
why your highest purpose will come from
helping people who are currently facing
that right now Anne in Sept 3 is the how
so how are you gonna do it there's a lot
of ways you can help people who are in
that situation
so for me break it down the who is my
one word it's believed the wise helping
entrepreneurs purpose come from my pain
now how do I help entrepreneurs how do I
believe in entrepreneurs is that there's
a ton of ways that I could be believing
in entrepreneurs so the example I use if
is if you are moving your office and you
need my help to rent a moving truck and
to help you carry your desks and all of
that stuff I love the end result of it I
love that now you have this great office
where you can build a business and have
it flourish and I'll Poli say yes to
helping you do that so if you're a close
friend but I don't love the process of
moving I don't love the process of
packing up boxes I don't love the
process of setting up cables and wires
and putting together an office I don't
love that process I love the result
because I'm believing in entrepreneurs
but I don't the process and so if you
write down you make a list of all the
things that you do the activities that
you have done that you've enjoyed the
result make a list of ten to fifteen
times you've helped somebody with that
same pain that you had growing up you've
helped them and you enjoyed the end
result and then circle the ones where
you enjoyed the process as well because
when you can enjoy the process and you
enjoy the end result it's a home run now
you've found your higher purpose now you
have clarity now you have a plan that's
the point of the purpose planner step
one you figure out your who your
one-word most important core value step
two you figure out your why your purpose
comes in your pain the thing that you
never want anybody to ever have to
experience again because it was so
painful for you and then step three is
the how the process you need to love the
process you should go those three things
you are set for life
if you want to learn how to stop wasting
your life away check the video there
right next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
99.9% of the people that watch or listen
to this content are living in the middle
doesn't mean you have to stop